[Musique]
comme des millions de Français notre
invité adore écouter de la musique c'est
l'une de ses grandes passions mais la
différence entre lui et nous c'est que
lui il en a fait son métier plus que ça
encore c'est lui qui a choisi produit et
lancé la plupart des morceaux que vous
écoutez à la radio ou écoutiez dans les
boîtes de nuit à seulement 33 ans il
était déjà le patron de la plus grande
maison de disque du pays durant sa
carrière il a travaillé avec des
artistes comme Johnny ALID milen Farmer
Zaz Alain Bachou Julien claire Khaled il
a développé la carrière en France de
stars comme Bruce springstein George
Michael Sting Lionel Richie Eminem Lady
Gaga et ça ne s'est pas arrêté après son
départ d'Universal tant que j'ai la
passion je continuerai dit-il alors il
continue avec hashtag NP son label
indépendant 6 et7 il dit chercher des
artistes qu'on écoutera après sa mort
mais en trouve-t-il encore est-ce que ce
n'est pas plus difficile de trouver la
perle rare depuis que des artistes se
produisent et se diffusent eux-mêmes sur
TikTok est-ce que la musique n'est pas
en train d'échapper un peu au producteur
posons-lui toutes ses questions
bienvenue dans un monde d' un regard et
bienvenue à vous Pascal necre merci
d'avoir accepté notre invitation ici au
Sénat au Dom Tournon j'ai l'impression
que la musique ne cesse de vivre des
révolutions il y a eu ces questions de
téléchargement illg illégaux il y a eu
le streaming aujourd'hui ces artistes
qui émergent sur TikTok un peu par
eux-mêmes est-ce que vous vous sentez
parfois dépasser est-ce que vous arrivez
à suivre et comment vous faites pour
suivre alors euh de tout temps il y a
des artistes qui essayaient d'émerger
alors c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui les
réseaux sociaux leur permettent de se
créer une audience et de commencer à
avoir des fans alors qu'à l'époque ép
bah ils envoyaient des cassettes en
maison de disque et si il tournent c'est
le seul vecteur qui existait à l'époque
c'était la scène aujourd'hui les réseaux
sociaux sont un un autre vecteur qui
n'empêche pas la scène d'ê toujours très
important dans plein de genrees musicaux
je pense au rock je pense à la pop c'est
important vous continuez d'c vous
essayer de repérer des gens dans des
petites salles de concert ou vous allez
aussi sur les réseaux sociaux est-ce que
vous allez sur les deux les deux bon
sachant que c'est comme vous avez pu
remarquer plus
de regarder TikTok chez soi que bon mais
non c'est formidable mais c'est vrai que
tout à coup ça change tout le processus
de
création la première chose c'est que
aujourd'hui plus de 60 % des des
musiques que vous entendez sont
produites par l'artiste lui-même
d'accordà ça c'est la première chose
donc c'est une vraie question ça c'est
donc il y a vraiment le poids de
l'autproduction est devenu très très
important deuxièement quand vous signez
avec un un label vous pouvez signer avec
plusieurs formes de relation soit vousre
un artiste soit tout à coup vous vous
produisez vous allez voir le label avec
vos bandes vous avez déjà enregistré où
on vous a donné une avance pour vous
permettre d'enregistrer et là le label
va vous conseiller en terme de promotion
de marketing puis de vente soit vous
êtes assez grand et vous faites tout
tout seul vous demandez juste à la
maison disque de vous distribuer
et vous donner une avance donc c'est
vrai qu'
aujourd'hui c'est assez spectaculaire du
côté des des majeurs
où de plus en plus les majeurs sont des
distributeurs et plus des producteurs
donc le métier de producteur change le
métier de producteur change imaginez
qu'aujourd'hui les les trois majur
représentent moins de 10 % de la
production 90 % sont soit des
producteurs indépendants soit des
artistes qui se produisent vous pensez
que le métier de producteur pourrait
disparaître alors non parce que je pense
qu' on ne réussit pas tout seul un
artiste il a besoin d'être entouré alors
il sera entouré par un producteur ou il
sera entouré par un
manager et puis producteur il y a
différents producteurs de plus en plus
aujourd'hui les producteurs sont à la
fois des producteurs de disque est-ce
qu'on ose encore parler de disque
d'ailleurs où sont des producteurs de de
spectacle souvent ils font les deux donc
vous allez avoir besoin d'avoir des
alliés on réuss un artiste ne réussit
est seul vous avez d'ailleurs une belle
définition du producteur vous dites
c'est dénicher un talent en être
convaincu de manière irrationnelle lui
signer un contrat choisir les musiciens
et les techniciens puis lui faire
rencontrer son public c'est un peu comme
un entraîneur sportif dites-vous c'est
un compagnon dans le sens latin du terme
celui avec qui l'on partage le pain la
comppagé oui c'est le mot irrationnel
moi que que je retiens aussi de cette
phrase il y a quelque chose
d'irrationnel dans la rencontre entre un
producteur et un artiste ouais mais
c'est c'est comme une histoire d'amour
parce que la chose la plus importante
entre un producteur et un artiste ou un
manager un agent et un artiste c'est la
confiance et donc tout à coup vous allez
créer une relation de confiance et tant
que cette relation de confiance est là
vous avancez si un jour elle se casse
faut arrêter parce que ça marchera plus
ça ça on pourra plus fonctionner voilà
mais ça veut dire que parfois peut-être
certains de vous ont pas compris dans
vos choix est-ce que ça vous est arrivé
qu'on vous dise non mais là tu vas te
planter tu t'es trompé d'avoir repéré
avoir repérer des talents et qu'on vous
dise mais non mais là tu te trompes
mais je vous parlerai de tous les
artistes avecquels j'ai travaillé qui
ont connu le succès parce que ça serait
trop long de vous parler de tous les
artistes que j'ai signé qui ont pas
marché donc la règle c'était à peu près
si vous êtes bon c'est sur six artistes
que vous signez il y en a un qui marche
bien sûr donc donc c'est vous pouvez pas
à chaque fois réussir quoi ce qui est
normal
euh vous savez le succès ça c'est
toujours un petit miracle hein ou
toujours alors moi je sais pas ce qui
fait le succès je je peux vous faire la
liste de ce qui ne fera pas le succès si
tu fais ça ça marchera pas mais en
revanche qui va faire que le public va
être là qu'est-ce que vous en savez ça
va même plus loin vous pouvez faire 300
ou 400000 personnes followers sur TikTok
ou et puis vous sortez un titre vous
allez avoir de streaming donc attention
la notoriété céit pas obligatoirement le
succès hein
vous dites quelque chose de que je
trouve très intéressant sur les artistes
vous dites ce qui fait un artiste c'est
sa signature vocale il faut un défaut
dans la voix si tu as une voix parfaite
tu finis chiste dites-vous les gens ont
du mal à entendre que ce sont leurs
défauts qui les rendent unique c'est par
un défaut qu'on se démarque alors moi
personnellement j'ai toujours été
convaincu que la personnalité de
quelqu'un ouais ce sont ses défauts vous
réfléchissez 2 minutes à des copains les
gens de votre famille si vous voulez les
décrire en deux mots et ben vous allez
voir que souvent c'est un défaut mais
défaut C défaut c'est ce qui fait la
force de votre personnalité euh donc
voilà c'est c'est je dirais les qualités
c'est plutôt les creux et les pointes
sont plutôt les défut sont les aspérités
bien sûr quelles sont les aspérités de
milen farmer les défauts de milen farmer
les défauts de Johnny hidday les défauts
de Julien
claire Julien claire combien de fois les
gens il y avait plein de gens qui
critiquaient sa voix en disant il a une
voix qui tremble mais c'est la signature
de cl c'est la gature de Julien cler
donc
voilà donc c'est c'est c'est vrai que je
suis convaincu que le notre meilleur ami
ce sont nos défauts alors après
évidemment il faut il faut les utiliser
les canaliser mais je pense que c'est ce
qui fait une personnalité et
effectivement un chanteur qui n'a pas de
défaut bah vous allez pas reconnaître en
2 secondes sa voix il sera choriste ça
donne beaucoup d'espoir j'imagine à
plein d'artistes qui peut-être nous
suivent et nous écout non non mais
attendez avoir un défaut dans la voix
c'est pas pas chanter faux hein mais
c'est d'avoir une aspérité un truc
différent qui fait que on vous écoute
une seconde vous savez qui qui vous êtes
quand j'écoute une nouvelle production
dites-vous je monte naturellement le son
quand ça me plaît c'est souvent le futur
single je ne saurais pas l'expliquer
c'est physique inconscient là aussi he
il y a quelque chose d'un peu
irrationnel pour qui vous montez le son
aujourd'hui plein de gens mais mais
c'est vrai que c'est assez amusant et ça
j'avais repéré et c'est pas moi qui
l'avais repéré céit c'est les gens qui
venaient me voir qui avaient repéré que
j'écoutis tout à coup je faisais ça et
en général quand je faisais ça c'est que
il se passait un truc et là on est dans
un truc compltement irrationnel mais ce
qui est génial de notre métier c'est que
le fondamental il est irrationnel on est
dans la poésie on est dans les
mélodies donc on est dans l'art donc
c'est au départ c'est complètement
irrationnel après vous allez essayer de
le rationaliser mais au départ c'est
complètement irrationnel bien sûr on va
parler un peu économie musicale est-ce
qu'il est viable le modèle économique
aujourd'hui dans le monde de la de la
musique pour les artistes et pour les
producteurs alors le modèle est en train
de changer ouais grosso modo la grande
révolution elle a pas trop été le
téléchargement parce que que j'achète un
disque ou j'achète un téléchargement
c'est la même chose le le changement de
paradigme est arrivé avec avec le
streaming payant parce que tout à coup
vous n'achetez plus vous ne possédez
plus mais vous payez un abonnement pour
avoir accès à toute la
musique donc ça ça a été c'est une vraie
révolution
euh pour la petite histoire les deux
premiers pays où ont démarré le
streaming payant ça a été la Suède
Spotify et la France
10h et c'est très intéressant parce
qu'on est sur une chaîne parlementaire
de repérer que c'est les deux seuls pays
qui avaient fait passer une loi pour
lutter contre la
piraterie donc de temps en temps on a
l'impression de faire des CADES
juridiques qui n'ont aucun sens sauf que
parce que vous faites un cas juridique
vous permettez à un nouveau modèle et
qui est un modèle fondamental qui est
aujourd'hui le streaming payant
d'émerger et en Suède les les les les
débats laadopi ça va été très violent en
France mais alors en Suède c'était
tellement violent qu'il y a eu un parti
pirate qui a été
créé don donc c'est intéressant de voir
que là où a démarré le nouveau modèle
mondial aujourd'hui de la musique qui
est du qui streaming h payant par
abonnement il a été fait dans deux pays
dans lequels il y avait un juridique
vous assumez complètement vous
l'expression industrie culturelle en
2015 lorsque vous étiez encore patron
d'Universal vous disiez ceci je
revendique à 100 % cette logique
économique la nié c'est revenir au
messena et si le messen n'avait pas de
goût là c'est le public qui décide le
capitalisme c'est la démocratie oui la
musique est aussi un produit de
consommation comment on fait de la
musique grand publicque sans perdre en
exigence artistique mais parce
queaujourd'hui au débat vous faites de
la musique et c'est et c'est le grand
public qui qui le qui qui adhère et et
qui et qui va l'écouter le consommer
donc clairement oui il il est il est le
plus important c'est que ça soit produit
c'est-à-dire que je pense que l'offre
culturelle c'est une offre et donc il
est fondamental que c'est danger pour
moi du streaming aujourd'hui c'est que
le streaming a fait le plein sur les
moins de 25 ans donc les grosses maisons
10ques ont tendance à signer que de la
musique pour moins de 25 ans désolé la
majorité des Français ont plus de 25 ans
donc il faut faire attention qu'à un
moment donné on n'est pas plus que des
esthétiques pour les moins de 25 et il
est fondamental que le classique le jazz
la World musi le rock la variété
française puisse continuer à exister euh
donc il y a un risque que l'offre
s'atrophie C seulement les jeunes si à
un moment donné il y a il y a
aujourd'hui essentiellement que les
jeunes qui sont sur streaming le danger
c'est que oui on est une appauvrissement
de la
production si vous regardez les chiffres
d'écoute en fonction des genres
musicaux par exemple la musique urbaine
aujourd'hui fait sur la nouveauté fait à
peu près la moitié des écoutes aux
États-Unis c'est 13 % oui oui donc voilà
alors il y a sûrement le fait que il y a
un peu il y a des faux stream mais mais
attention je dis c'est pour ça que il y
a un enjeu majeur aujourd'hui que S
c'est dal de la musique il il y a quand
même une différence entre les impératifs
commerciaux de producteur que vous êtes
et l'envie artistique aussi comment on
arrive à concilier les injonctions qui
semblent contrairees non il y en a pas
mais non bah si un artiste ne fait pas
ce qu'il aime ah c'est c'est cuit
d'entrée non mais il peut céder à la
pression en se disant bon bah si c'est
ça qui doit marcher alors bah je vais je
vais plier et puis je vais céder ce que
à ce que me demande le producteur au
secours ça ça marche pas ça ça marche
pas ouais ça marche pas euh ça j'y crois
pas il y a jamais de litige entre un
producteur et son artiste sû si mais là
on peut dire attention je trouve que
tourfin est pas assez fort je trouve que
les paroles de ce scoupl bon ça dit rien
voilà il peut y avoir des discussions
mais mais fondamentalement l'artiste
c'est le boss mais sinon ça marche pas
vous pouvez pas demander à quelqu'un de
chanter les choses qu'il aime pas
surtout s'il les fait donc ça a aucun
sens l'artiste c'est le boss donc reste
bossment plus que jamais plus que jamais
vous l' on l'a dit tout à l'heure de
plus en plus les artistes se produisent
on est vraiment aujourd'hui on a été
très longtemps dans un modèle de
producteur centrique oui d'accord le
centre c'était le producteur aujourd'hui
on est dans un modèle d'artiste
centrique le centre de tout c'est
l'artiste euh votre grande particularité
à vous et on l'entend d'ailleurs dans ce
que vous dites c'est que vous êtes
toujours resté au contact des artistes
même même au plus haut de la pyramide
vous n'avez jamais lâché le terrain les
studios d'enregistrement et vous avez
dit un jour il est déjà arrivé que je
fasse réécrire des disques complets
réenregistré des titres trois fois ce
n'est pas tabou c'est pousser l'artiste
jusqu'au bout de sa création et l'aider
à prendre son envol l'artiste attend les
critiques elles sont importantes et
l'expérience nous a souvent donné raison
est-ce qu'il y a eu aussi une envie
parfois au fond en vous d'être à leur
place non JIS oh là là là là non j'avais
entendu chanter c'est une catastrophe oh
une fois j'étais avec Johnny et on est
en train de réfléchir sur le track
listing la liste des chansons qu'il
allait faire sur la tourée suivante et
je luis dit oh là là là il faudrait que
tu fasses cette chanson attends je me
rappelle plus du titre dit chante la moi
donc je commence à chanter et il dit que
je n'ai jamais chanté ça moi et après
c'était je ne sais plus c'était pas
Gabriel enfin c'est ce genre de truc qu
donc une catastrophe donc c'est donc non
non je suis pas j'ai jamais voul être à
leur place non en revanche c'est vrai
que de temps en temps vous pouvez sentir
que le titre il est pas totalement
abouti l'artiste il peut aller plus loin
et vous devez le pousser à aller plus
loin je je pense que là vous l'aidez
vous l'aidez oui mais pour ça il faut
être légitime à ses yeux et peut-être
que des artistes vous mais attends tu as
jamais chanté de ta vie ou tu as jamais
touché un instrument de musique de ta
vie c'est jamais arrivé ça qu'on vous
dise bah tues critiques elles sont si si
j'ai eu un artiste chantit j'étais pas
encore né bon mais mais bon et après bon
mais non non mais mais c'est oui mais
c'est là où il y a la confiance oui
c'estàdire que tout à coup vous dites
tiens si me dit ça est-ce que je peux
faire mieux puis à un moment donné ça
arrive à un point où nonous on peut pas
faire mieux et ben on y va c'eston bon
tu as le
définitif je voudrais qu'on parle un
petit peu de du rapport entre musique et
télévision il y a la star Académie sur
TF1 qui continue émission à laquelle
vous avez déjà participé il y a The
Voice il y a aussi culture box quelques
Liv aussi dans C'est à vous dans
quotidien il y a évidemment Taratata de
temps en temps de façon un peu
sporadique à la télévision vous faites
partie de ceux qui disent que c'est trop
peu que ça manque la vraie musique à la
télévision c'est dommage queil y ait pas
assez de musique à la télévision ou pas
oui il y a pas assez de musique à la
télévision pourquoi d'après vous ça
marche pas la musique à la télé oui
alors on dit que ça marche pas c'est à
quoi j'ai tendance à penser de trouver
trouver les formats qui feront que ça
marche euh qu'on me dise qu'aujourd'hui
on peut plus faire les formats des
années 80 j'entends à trouvz en d'autres
mais vous y croyez vous pensez que ça
marcherait pas une émission de variété
toute je crois
que avec le fait qu'aujourd'hui avec
l'éclatement du PAF qui fait que
aujourd'hui la la les parts de marché
des des chaînes sont beaucoup plus
faibles qu'avant je pense que la musique
devrait avoir beaucoup plus de place à
ce que je pense le seul problème qu'on
ne dit pas c'est que une émission de
variété ça coûte cher à produire
ah et que c'est pas considéré comme des
émissions de stock donc vous n'avez pas
d' CNC compagnie d'accord voilà la
problématique et je trouve ça absolument
fou de dire que ce sont pas des des des
des des émissions de stock parce queil y
a des chaînes aujourd'hui qui
rediffusent les carpentiers et cetera et
les gens ont plaisir à le regarder euh
et que bizarrement souvent la les les
variétés ont moins vieilli que les de
les feuilletons des des années 60 70
donc bon vous avez vu il y a une
plateforme qui s mis c'est c'est Netflix
qui a sorti nouvelle école pour ceux qui
connaissent pas c'est une émission c'est
une sorte de starac mais version rap he
c'est ça ça vous regardez vous aimez
vous c'est un modèle qui peut marcher B
pourquoi ça marcherait pas alors là on
att je pense qu'il y a une espèce de
nostalgie C tempsci dans la télé parce
que là il y a Stara qui est revenu euh
et c'est c'est bien c'est bien que tout
à coup on chante des des des chansons du
patrimoine et ceetera parce qu'il y a
beaucoup de des repris qui est normal et
c'est très bien bon il y a popstar aussi
qui est en train d'être monté sur Amazon
donc il y a des retours d'ancien format
bon super je me réjouis moi il y a The
Voice qui continue à cartonner donc tant
mieux mais plus il y a d'émissions à la
télé mais là on parle voyez sur sur un
The Voice sur instarac certes il y a
quelques artistes installés le reste ce
sont des des artistes en herbe qui sont
en train d'essayer de grandir c'est vrai
que je je trouve ça un peu triste qu'on
nit pas plus d'espace pour pour juste
bah montrer montrer nos artistes vous
l'avez dit tout à l'heure c'est la
musique urbaine qui qui tient la corde
aujourd'hui dans l'industrie musicale
les sons hip hop sont très nombreux les
sons afro poop aussi ouais qui émergent
depuis quelques années après les sons
rails que vous avez bien senti c'est
vous hein qui avez lancé le rail le rail
en France puisque dès que vous arrivez
chez Barkley vous demandez à signer
Khaled puis vous signez rachita déjà là
mais on développe on fait yaraya
ensemble et puis après on aé le petit
Faudel il était il avait 17 ans à
l'époque jeisbé sur on fait un de TR
soleil je suis tombé sur cette phrase
incroyable de vous vous dites je me
rappelle qu'à l'époque les patrons de
boîte de nuit me disaient on ne va pas
jouer la musique des gens qu'on ne fait
pas rentrer chez nous ouais et 8 mois
après ils faisaient tous un quart
d'heure oriental il y a eu cette musique
qui a déferel sur le pays mais je pense
que la musique c'est un truc génial
c'est que c'est c'est un art vraiment
populaire ouais c'est-à-dire que tout à
coup vous avez pas besoin de parler la
langue euh vous pouvez écouter des
chansons dont vous comprenez pas le
texte mais qui vont vous dire des choses
donc ça veut dire que la musique peut
faire changer la société peut ouvrir des
portes ouvrir des culture ouvrir vous
savez la musique elle a été elle a été
black bomber bien avant 98 et la Coupe
du Monde vous voyez ce que je veux dire
donc oui bien sûr elle est elle est la
musique elle est dans la rue donc tout à
coup elle elle voit ce qui se passe dans
la rue elle suit ce qui se passe dans la
rue euh et et et donc elle elle a ce
côté effectivement de de partager des
émotions des envies des cultures
différentes c'est génial j'ai un
document à vous proposer Pascal je
vais vous le mettre entre les mains et
puis je vais le décrire pour les gens
qui nous écoutent donc c'est une vue
générale du studio de la radio libre
radio tomate on est le 30 septembre 1981
à Paris lors de la diffusion d'une
interview du ministre de la Culture Jack
Lang cette radio venait d'être créée
pour ouvrir justement des nouveaux
espaces de débats d'information de
culture à l'époque c'est un peu du
bricolage he elle é mettait depuis ce
squat que vous voyez animé par des
militants ça a été un sacré tournant
pour vous dans votre histoire
personnelle l'arrivée de de la radio
livre oui c'est 81 mitéran moi j'ai 20
ans donc voilà je suis en train
d'étudier des mathématiques pour faire
plaisir à mes parents et puis et puis
voilà et puis je commence à être
animateur sur une petite radio libre
dans l'ouest de Paris et puis voilà quoi
et pu mais c'est à ce moment-là votre
coup de cœur pour le son pour musique
non c'est moi ce qui m'intéressait
d'abord c'était l'échange euh c'était ça
euh et donc ce que vous faites c'est
intéressant d'aller voir qui est l'autre
bon euh donc c'est donc c'est ça qui
m'intéressait et puis après je deviens
donc j'ai une émission puis après je
deviens directeur de la programmation
donc c'est là où jeis faire ma culture
musicale et puis ensuite pas trop la
station et puis à un moment donné les
maisons disqu envoyer des
nouveaux des nouveaux artistes faire ce
qu'on appelle aujourd'hui training il y
avait trois grosses radios à l'époque
Hertel Europe RMC évidemment le service
public en plus et donc les les nouveaux
artistes avant les balancer sur RTL il y
avait beaucoup d'audien il les envoyé
s'entraîner sur les les radios et donc
la première interview de Marc Lavoine
c'est moi qui l'ai faite et d'ailleurs
c'est c'est il me répondait oui non 1
heure c'est long même pas oui mais non
peut-être oui non était terrorisé voilà
une des premières intervie de min Farmer
c'est moi mais ce qui est drôle c'est
qui aurait dit que des années après on
allit on allitoss ensemble vous ne venez
pas du tout du monde de la musique au
départ hein vos parents étaient employés
de PTT l'ancêtre de la Poste vos
grands-parents agriculteurs vous dites
d'ailleurs que vous n'oubliez pas d'où
vous venez votre premier concert c'est à
12 ans je crois Michel fugin oui le BC
bazar et vous faites et vous l'avez dit
des études de mathématiques parce que
vous êtes plutôt doué et que ça rassure
votre père vous faites même une prépa
matsup je crois que vos parents vous
rêvent ingénieur ou banquier est-ce que
vous étiez trop rock and roll pour ça
vous ne pouviez pas suivre cette voix
qui était non je pense que j'ai jamais
été dans un moule ouais euh voilà j'ai
très peur des gens qu'on met dans des
moules dans les casses moi j'étais pas
fait pour ça vous es un ovni vous é OV
dans et c'est ah bah mes parents sont
fait beaucoup de soucis longtemps sur
mon avenir
mais mais je pense que après il faut
faut écouter ses passions après je c'est
vrai
que à la fin quand j'ai compris que les
radiolip ça allêre des réseaux que moi
j'allais pas travailler sur un réseau
c'est là où les maisons j'avais les
relations avec les maisons j'ai commencé
j'ai un petit attaché de fr indépendant
puis j'ai grandi moi je au SMIC puis
j'ai appris mon métier sur le tas donc
voilà quoi mais je pense qu'il y avait
après oui une vraie passion pour la
musique et puis une passion pour
toujours les artistes c'est des gens
intéressants c'est des gens vous savez
travailler pour plus grand que soi c'est
c'est passionnant à la lueur de celui
que vous êtes aujourd'hui Pascal
quel conseil donneriez-vous au petit
garçon qui va se lancer dans la vie
c'est d'écouter ce qu'on a envie de
faire et je être fr au départ on sait
pas ou on fait des études on en fait pas
qu'est-ce qu'on va faire j'en sais rien
je pense qu'il faut écouter ces passions
moi je pense que la pire chose chez
quelqu'un c'est de pas avoir une passion
voilà je trouve que mais même si c'est
la pêche mais mais
mais je dis ça avec moi j'adore pêcheer
mais la pêche mais mais il y a un moment
donné si personnes si vous avez pas une
passion dans votre vie c'est terrible
quelque chose qui vous a qui vous anime
et deuxièmement pas oublier que la
moitié de sa vie on travaille hein parce
que j'enlève la part le moment où on
dort la moitié de votre vie réveillée
vous travaillez essayez de faire un truc
qui vous éclate parce que passer la
moitié votre vie à vous embêter c'est
c'est trouve ça terrifiant très bon
conseil j'ai des photos à vous proposer
ouais alors première photo je sais pas
si vous allez le reconnaître il s'agit
de her Kelly rappeur américain condamné
à 30 ans de prison pour CRIM sexuel il y
a lui mais je pourrais citer p Didi
accusé de viol Kenny West qui enchaîne
les dérapages en France on a quelques
rappeurs qui ont des problèmes aussi
avec la justice est-ce que le milieu hip
hop est plus compliqué à gérer vous qui
avez été aussi au contact de ce milieu
est-ce que c'est plus compliqué que de
gérer zasi par exemple c'est difficile
de de gérer ces artistes il y a toujours
eu des histoires
euh sauf que aujourd'hui elles
sont à la fois il y a je m'en réjouis
d'ailleurs
euh les gens osent plus facilement dire
non oui ils devaient pas me faire ça je
pense qu'à une époque les gens n'osaient
pas les femmees faut être franc euh et
deuxièmement il y a les réseaux sociaux
euh moi je trouve que le fait que la
parole ce soit ouverte c'est fondamental
c'est absolument fondamental une
dernière photo cette fois il s'agit
d'eltton John je sais pas si vous le
reconnaissez alors lui il s'était fait
surtout connaître pour ses fantaisies
vestimentaires on a aussi souvent parlé
de vos fantaisies ves ent à vous de vos
couleurs est-ce que le le monde manque
un peu de fantaisie aujourd'hui bah
c'est vrai que moi moi je suis arrivé
dans le disque c'était la fin parce que
c'était la fin du Viny la
cassette sur lesquel les gens copient
fait que le marché é TR de s'écrouler
puis est arrivé le CD et donc le CD a
relancé jusqu'en en France jusquen 2002
à relancer l'industrie et c'est vrai que
moi j'ai connu des années où on
s'amusait on riait j'ai le sentiment
aujourd'hui que ça rigole beaucoup moins
alors que avec le streaming le marché
est en train de remonter alors on n'est
pas arrivé au pic de 2003 mais il
remonte mais j'ai l'impression que ça
s'amuse pas il y a pas je ne sais pas je
ne sais pas alors est-ce que c'est
beaucoup est-ce que est-ce que les gens
sont beaucoup plus autocentrés h euh
deuxièmement je pense que la fête c'est
aussi aller de aller dans des endroits
pour faire la fête et je je pense que il
y a un appareil qui s'appelle un
téléphone portable qui a un gros défaut
c'est qu'il a un appareil photo fait que
les gens quand ils sont connus ils ont
pas envie parce que ils vont dans un
endroit et ils vont se prendre 253
photos bon qui seront toujours pas très
réussies sur les réseaux sociaux donc
c'est vrai que peut-être que c'est ça où
qui fait qu'aujourd'hui il y a moins la
fête qu'avant je sais pas mais je trouve
que c'est vrai que c'est moins il y a
moins de joie moins de fantaisie oui je
je ne comprends pas pourquoi on est
entouré de quatre statutes dans ce lieu
un peu particulier il est quatre statues
qui chacune représente une vertu par
qu'Al il y a ici la sagesse la
prudence la justice et l'éloquance et le
rituel de cette émission c'est de
demander à notre invité dans laquelle de
ces vertus il se reconnaît le
plus je suis un chatcheur donc j'irai
l'éloquance mais mais pour moi le plus
important c'est la justice
pourquoi parce
que les les les combats justement don on
parlait tout à l'heure qui est qui est
Mitou mais non mais qui est juste euh
l'égalité homme-femme
euh dans un métier qui qui est compliqué
pour les femmes on oublie de le dire
mais la majorité des artistes qui ont du
succès sont des hommes sont pas des
femmes hein bon à voir citez-moi le
nombre d'artistes vous parliez de zasi
tout à l'heure milen Farmer il y a
combien d'artistes qui ont qui ont 30 30
ans de carrière il y a la féminine il y
en a pas beaucoup des garçons vous allez
m'en faire des beau temps donc il y a de
l'injustice donc la justice ça le la la
capacité même si ça évolue mais je
trouve ça 10 fois trop lent euh est-ce
que vous trouvez normal que moi en 90 je
le premier à embaucher un un chef de
produit qui est qui est qui est qui est
black mais on est chez on est chez les
fou dans la musique bon et je trouve que
là aussi je trouve que ça avance mais
euh mais que les minorités puissent être
plus importantes mais qu'on soit euh que
dans les maisons disques on on ressemble
aux artistes qu'on produit enfin bon je
trouve que là-dessus il y a beaucoup il
y a la justice c'est important VO ben ce
sera votre mot votre mot de la fin de
cet entretien merci infiniment Pascal
d'avoir été avec nous merci à vous de
nous avoir suivi comme chaque semaine
émission évidemment retrouver en podcast
si vous le souhaitez à très bientôt sur
public Sena
[Musique]
merci